This gets us directly towards our homework.
I want you to build a tool called Bonsaikon, for Bonsai Daikon
or tiny Daikon.
The idea is to take a number of executions, like these,
and produce assertions, that is,
invariants that hold for all runs observed.
For the starting point, all I want from you is ranges of variables
as you have seen them.
What Bonsaikon should produce is a range
of variable values seen at the call and at the return of each function.
Here is an example, for square root, how this should look like.
At the call of the square root function,
x is always between 2 and 16.
And the variable epsilon is always 10 to the power of minus 7.
And as you can see, I want you to output these ranges
and if the range has just one value, then I want this to be an equal sign.
I want you to output these as assertions that can be
inserted immediately into the code.
This would be pre conditions that hold when a function is called,
but I also want you to report post conditions
that hold when the function returns.
Here we have the range for the variable y at the end of square root
and also the return value,
which I gave this special name, "ret."
Return value is between square root of 2 and square root of 16
as seen for these 3 runs.
The question is how do you get these ranges?
The answer to that, again, is our tracing function,
which allows us to record the state of the program at every call
and at every return.
What you set up is a special trace-it function,
which gets the current frame that executed,
the event that's taken place, and an argument.
Let's first take a look at the event.
The event is either call or return,
which translates directly into these two situations you'd like to monitor.
The current frame tells you which code is being executed.
frame.f-code.co-name gives you the name of the function that's executed.
In our case, that would be square root.
The frame.f-locals attribute is a dictionary
that gives you access to all local variables
such as y or x or eps.
And finally, if the event is returned, the argument that's passed over here
gives you the return value.
So what you do is you run your program with the trace function enabled.
You record the call and return events.
You check for every single function that's being called.
and is called and is returned.
You check all the variables through frame f-locals,
and over time you record the ranges.
When the execution is done, you output the ranges that you have observed.
So in the beginning, first run, square root of 2, x is just 2.
Then x is between 2 and 4.
And then x is between 2 and 16.
Likewise, for y where the square root gets extended over time.
Likewise for the return value, where again the range of return values
extends as more and more runs are observed.